.
ANTHONY FAUCI MANDATE FREEDOM.
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Greg: I DIDN'T READ THIS BY
THE WAY.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: CLAP LIKE YOU ARE AN
AUDIENCE AND NOT SOME EMPLOYEES
I DRAGGED IN HERE.
HOW WAS YOUR VALENTINE'S DAY
DAY.
KAT SPENT THE NIGHT IN CUFF.
WE COULD HAVE SPENT IT IN JAIL
AS WELL.
THE BUREAU OF ALCOHOL, TOBACCO
AND FIREARMS AND EXPLOSIVES
TWEETED A PLEA IT SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT A FORMER
PARTNER INVOLVED IN ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
WE WILL MAKE SURE IT'S
A VALENTINE'S DAY TO REMEMBER.
YOU KNOW I AM A LAW AND ORDER
GUY.
NOT THE SHOW.
THAT SUCKS.
I MEAN THE REAL THING.
THIS CREEPED ME OUT.
YOU NEVER WANT TO RELY ON BITTER
EXES FOR ANYTHING.
THEY COULD CALLED 9-11 AND SAY
YOU BE HOLD UP IN A BASEMENT.
WITH REALLY YOU ARE JUST EATING
PIZZA IN YOUR UNDERWEAR.
WE OBTAINED THE FIRST FEW PHONE
CALLS TO THE ATF.
>> [PHONE RINGING].
>> WHAT IS YOUR EMERGENCY?
>> MY WIFE IS EH RATTIC.
DRUNK AND DOING ARTS AND CRAFTS.
>> DOES SHE HAVE A GUN?
>> YES, SHE IS USING IT TO STICK
RHINESTONES EVERYWHERE.
>> THAT'S A HOT GLUE GUN.
>> SHE HAS A VAN FULL OF AMMON
IUM NITRATE.
>> WE ARE ON OUR WAY.
>> MY HUSBAND IS ACTING CRAZY.
>> ALCOHOL OR TOBACCO INVOLVED?
>> NO.
>> FIREARMS?
>> WE JUST WATCHED ALL OF THE
DIRTY HARRY MOVIES.
>> WE WILL BE RIGHT THERE.
>> MY BOYFRIEND LEFT FOR WORK
AND HE IS BEING SUCH A JERK.
THERE ARE WEAPONS IN THE HOUSE?
>> NO, I AM BY MYSELF.
JUST ME AND MY BIKINI.
>> YOU CALLED THE BUREAU OF
ALCOHOL, TOBACCO AND FIREARMS?
>> OH, I LOVE A MAN IN UNIFORM.
I AM SO LONELY.
ARE YOU LONELY.
>> SO THERE IS NO GUN PRESENT?
>> I THOUGHT MAYBE YOU COULD
BRING YOURS.
I NEED THE LONG ARM OF THE LAW.
>> OH, BOY.
I WILL BE RIGHT OVER.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
IT WON'T CATCH CRIMINALS.
WHAT IS NEXT STARTING A FIGHT AT
THANKSGIVING TO SEE WHICH
RELATIVE IS STRAPPED?
WE KNOW SNITCHES GETS STITCHES.
MARTHA HAS THAT TATTOOED ON HER
ANKLE.
IT WAS A CUTE IDEA.
BUT IT HELPED NO ONE.
ESPECIALLY KRISTENA WHO WAS
MURDERED BY A HOMELESS THIEF WHO
STABBED HER 40 TIMES IN HER
APARTMENT.
THE KILLER LIVING IN A SHELTER
BECAUSE THERE IS NO PLACE FOR
THE CRIMMINALLY DERAGED.
THEY SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN HIM
A JOB AS A CNN PRODUCER.
HE WAS FREED ON SUPERVISED
RELEASE.
HOW DOES THAT WORK.
UNLESS THAT MEANS A COP
FOLLOWING THE CYCLE AROUND I
DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT IT.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
THIS GUY IS LOCKED UP AND
FIGURED OUT HOW TO STAY
ARRESTED.
MURDER SOMEONE.
THAT'S THE BAR FOR INCLUSION
WHICH IS THE THING USED BY
GANGS.
IT ONLY ONE OF THE KILLER'S EXES
SAW THE ATF TWEET WE COULD HAVE
TRICKED HIM AND SLAPPED THE
CUFFS ON HIM.
YOU DON'T EVEN LOCK UP THE
PEOPLE YOU ALREADY BUSTED.
IT'S THE CART BEFORE THE POLICE
HORSE.
MAYBE FIGURE OUT HOW TO KEEP
THESE MONSTERS BEHIND BARS
BEFORE YOU FIGURE OUT CLEVER
WAYS TO GRAB MORE.
LOOK AT WHAT WE DID 5 YEARS AGO
BEFORE DEMOCRATS SCREWED THIS
[BLEEP] UP.
HEINOUS CRIMINALS ROAM LIKE FREE
RANGE CHICKENS.
THESE CRIMES KEEP HAPPENING.
OUTRAGE ON FOX AND THEN IT'S
FORGOTTEN.
MANY VICTIMS ARE ASIAN.
WHEN WILL THE ASIAN LEADERS DO
SOMETHING BIG.
HOMELESS THUGS DON'T READ TWEETS
FROM THE MAYOR'S OFFICE.
THERE IS NO ASIAN LIVES MATTER
FIGHTING ON YOUR BEHALF.
DON'T EXPECT HELP FROM THE DEMS.
THEY LITERALLY DOUBT THAT WOMEN
EXIST.
AOC JUST BLAMED THE CRIME SURGE
ON THE EXPIRED CHILD TAX CREDIT.
>> WE DON'T WANT TO SAY THINGS
THAT ARE OBVIOUS.
THE CHILD TAX CREDIT JUST RAN
OUT ON 31st AND NOW PEOPLE ARE
STEALING BABY FORMULA.
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
WE WANT TO SAY THESE PEOPLE ARE
CRIMINALS OR TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT ARE VIOLENT INSTEAD OF
ENVIRONMENTS OF VIOLENCE.
AND WHAT WE ARE DOING TO
CONTRIBUTE OR TO DISMANTLE THAT.
>> Greg: MY GOD.
THAT'S CAUSING ALL OF THE SMASH
AND GRAB AND CARJACKINGS AND
STABBING.
WHAT AN IGNORANT STATEMENT.
THESE ENVIRONMENTS OF VIOLENT
WERE NOT SO VIOLENT BEFORE LOONS
LIKE HER GOT INTO POWER.
PLANNING TRIPS TO FLORIDA.
WE TALKED TO THE VICTIM'S
FAMILIES AND POURED OVER THE
STATS AND NOT ONE PERSON WAS
BEATEN TO DEATH FOR BABY
FORMULA.
THE PEOPLE STRUGGLING ARE NOT
STEALING BABY FORMULA.
THEY ARE NOT SAFE ON THEIR WAY
HOME.
AOC THESE ARE WOMEN WHO BLEED TO
DEATH WHEN THEY ARE STABBED.
AOC CLAIMED HER LIFE WAS IN
DANGER BECAUSE OF A RIOT IN
A BUILDING SHE WAS NOT IN.
DISMISSES MURDER AS A PROBLEM
OVER TAXES?
WHAT IS NEXT.
THIS WOMAN WAS NOT BUTCHERED TO
DEATH OVER BABY FORMULA.
SHE WAS A YOUNG ASIAN WOMAN
FOLLOWED TO HER HOME.
WITH THEY DUSTED THE MURDER
SCENE FOR PRINTS THEY MAY
HAVEN'T FOUND YOUR AOC BUT YOUR
BAD IDEAS WERE AN ACCESSORY.
HOSTED OF THE "STORY" MARTHA
MacCALLUM.
SHE'S BEEN IN MORE LOCKER ROOMS
THAN ATHLETE'S FOOT.
MICHELLE.
AND KAT TIMPF.
AND HE USES A LEAF BLOWER TO
MAKE A SALAD.
TIRES!
MICHELLE, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
.
>> I AM EXCITED TO BE HERE.
>> Greg: WE ARE GOLDEN BEARS.
>> I SENT MY DIPLOMA BACK.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE REGRETS TOO?
IT WASN'T GOOD FOR ME EITHER.
AOC, TAX CREDIT, BABY FORMULA.
MURDER.
I MEAN IT'S SO SIMPLE.
>> SHE MIGHT HAVE LEARNED THAT
AT CAL.
THAT'S SO BIZARRE.
I GRABBLE WITH EVERY TIME SHE
SPEAKS.
I ASK MYSELF:
WHY DO WE PAY ATTENTION TO THIS
WOMAN?
SHE GETS TONS OF PUBLICITY
BECAUSE SHE IS A MASTER AT THAT.
PEOPLE NEED TO RESPOND TO THE
INSANITY SHE INTERVIEWS.
-- SPEWS.
SHE SAID THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING JOE BIDEN CAN DO IS POR55
STUDENT DEBT?
THIS WAS ONE OF THE HEADLINES IF
THE NEW YORKER.
-- SHE IS VERY OFF AND SAID THAT
CONGRESS IS IN DEEP [BLEEP].
IT'S BEEN THAT WAY FOR A LONG
TIME.
SHE DID NOT HELP.
>> Greg: SHE MAKES IT WORSE.
SHE THINKS HE IS ABOVE CONGRESS
AND LIVES IN AN ABSTRACT WORLD.
ALL OF THESE PRACTICAL THINGS
DON'T AFFECT HER.
IT'S DEFINITELY BABY FORMULA.
>> IT'S SO TWISTED.
IN WHAT WORLD DOES THIS WOMAN
WHO REPRESENTS NEW YORK NOT BEND
OVER BACKWARDS TO TALK ABOUT
THIS WOMAN WHO WAS FOLLOWED 6
FLIGHTS UP BY THIS MAN WHO IS
DERANGED AND ARRESTED 12 TIMES
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS?
WHY ISN'T SHE SCREAMING THAT
THIS MAN SHOULD BE IN JAIL AND
PROTECT THIS BEAUTIFUL YOUNG
WOMAN LIKE HERSELF THAT SHE HAS
NO SYMPATHY.
BLAMING IT ON BABY FORMULA.
THEY WERE WIPING IT OFF THE
SHELVES AND SELLING IT ON THE
BLACK MARKET.
SHE SAID WE IGNORE THE REASONS
BEHIND THINGS.
SHE IS IGNORING ALL OF THE
REASONS BEHIND THINGS.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON.
>> Greg: NO.
TYRUS HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
EX'S NARCING STORY.
>> I HAD 3 VISITS FROM THE
SHERIFF THIS WEEKEND.
>> [LAUGHING]>> A LOT OF STUFF.
THERE WERE NO WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
THAT WAS NICE.
THE IDEA TO PROMOTE NOT LETTING
IT GO AND PROMOTE STALKING IN
THE NAME OF THE LAW IS ABOUT AS
NORMAL AS SOMEONE SAYING TO AOC
WHEN SHE SAID LET'S HAVE THAT IT
CONVERSATION, GO.
YOU ARE WALKING OUT OF THAT
DROOLING AND WEALTH YOURSELF AT
THE RIDICULOUSNESS OF HER
COMMENTS.
THEY MAKE NO SENSE.
I THINK IT'S BY DESIGN.
HOW ARE YOU ARE A SOCIALIST WHEN
YOU ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT HOW
MUCH MONEY BUT GET PAID.
EITHER SHE WAS IS AN EVIL GENIUS
DOING THIS FOR SOME OTHER CRAZY
REASON OR NOBODY BOTHERED TO
READ THE ROW ASSUME AT THE
BOTTOM.
-- RESUME.
PEOPLE WHO VOTED WILL HAVE TO
LOOK IN THE MIRROR GOING SHE HAD
A FUTURE.
SHE HAD 2 VOWELS IN HER
NICKNAME.
YOU THOUGHT THAT MEANT SHE HAD
STUFF BEHIND IT.
>> Greg: [LAUGHING].
LET'S HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT CRIME.
>> NOBODY TALKS ABOUT BABY
POWDER.
>> Greg: NO BABY FORMULA.
>> NO ONE KNOWS BETTER THAN ME,
GREG.
[LAUGHING].
>> I CONFUSED THE TWO.
WAS THAT EMBARRASSING.
DON'T PUT ON LEATHER PANTS WITH
BABY FORMULA.
RIGHT, KAT?
>> OH!
>> Greg: EXCELLENT VOICE WORK
TODAY ON THE SKITS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Greg: THE PRESS SECRETARY
SAID THAT THE RISE IN VIOLENCE
IS BECAUSE OF HEIGHT  HATE
FILLED RHETORIC AROUND THE
PANDEMIC.
THE HOMELESS DUDES ARE UPSET
ABOUT ASIAN PEOPLE OVER THE
PANDEMIC.
>> I NEVER SEE THEM READING -- I
DON'T THINK THAT'S TRUE.
AOC, NOT ONLY DID SHE SAY SHOULD
GO THAT RIDICULOUS BUT SHE IS
LIKE NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT AND
SOMETIMES IT'S BECAUSE IT'S
DUMP.
HE IS NOT A SOCIALIST.
SHE HAS A FRENCH BULL DOG.
THAT'S NOT A RESCUE -- IT'S AN
EXPENSIVE DOG.
THEY DON'T HAVE SEX WITH EACH
OTHER.
THEY HAVE TO BE GENETICALLY
INJURED.
>> Greg: I BELIEVE EVERYTHING
SHE GETS IS FROM ANOTHER PERSON.
>> I AM NOT IN A POSITION OF
POWER.
>> Greg: YOU KIND OF.
>> BOO